i'm martha mccallum i'm bill hemmer i'm
shannon breme and this
is the fox news rundown
wednesday april 28 2021 i'm jessica
rosenthal
the president will address a joint
session of congress tonight just ahead
of his 100th day in office
and while he's receiving high praise
from democrats republicans feel
left out biden with all of his rhetoric
of
unity and bipartisanship has not really
demonstrated that
i'm dave anthony in the biden address to
the nation tonight
he might bring up his covet response
first
this president has taken action on the
major
issue confronting america in his first
100 days and
and i'm jason chaffetz i've got the
final word on the fox news rundown
[Music]
it's not a state of the union speech
presidents don't do those often in their
first year after having given an
inauguration speech
but tonight president biden will address
congress
just ahead of his 100th day in office
white house spokeswoman jen saki said
tuesday
the main highlight will be introducing
the american family's plan
which will focus on what she called
historic investment
in education and child care he will also
use the speech
as an opportunity to talk about many of
his other priorities including
police reform immigration gun safety his
ongoing work to get the pandemic under
control
and to putting americans back to work in
these first 100 days president biden has
done quite a bit
signing dozens of executive orders memos
and proclamations
many of them reversals of president
trump's policies
with the first action today uh we're
going to work to undo the moral and
national shame
of the previous administration that
literally not figuratively ripped
children from the arms of their families
their mothers and fathers at the border
he also reversed remain in mexico and
paused wall construction
and since he took office there's been an
unprecedented wave of central american
migrants arriving at the border
he rejoined the paris climate accord and
the world health organization
he's directed the justice department to
look at ways to ban ghost
guns and announced that troops will be
withdrawn from afghanistan on september
11th of this year
just this week he signed an order making
the minimum wage 15
an hour for federal contract workers and
he's revoked the permit
for the keystone xl pipeline and while
he's receiving high praise from
democrats
not so from the gop i'm going to act i'm
going to act
fast i'd like to be
i'd like to be doing it with the support
of republicans i've met with republicans
or some really fine people want to get
something done
but they're just not willing to go as
far as i think we have to go it is just
too far in many respects for many
republicans
well you know i was at the inauguration
it was all about unity bringing
the country together that we're too
divided and
i have to tell you everything i see has
been extremely partisan
in this first hundred days michael
mccall is a congressman representing the
10th district of texas
including the executive orders that
you're talking about
the keystone pipeline uh right out of
the box
hurting my state and energy state the
welders
you know the blue collar workers that
are really relying on that and then
i think the biggest mistake i've seen
and i've dealt the border my entire
professional career as a
federal prosecutor chairman of the
homeland security committee now
leader of the foreign affairs committee
is reversing
you know these asylum uh cooperation
agreements and remain in mexico policy
uh which has really created a
humanitarian crisis on the border
uh you know and i've been down there
many times and just
have never seen it this bad you know a
congressman as
central america central americans arrive
by the thousands to our border you know
we know in march
nearly 19 000 kids alone were
apprehended in that month
i imagine you think you should talk
about the border tonight but do you
think he will say anything different
than what he said at his first press
conference as president
about the border i would hope he would
i'm not even sure if he'll even bring it
up
i mean there's the reason they don't
even want to go down there
is because they know the obstacles are
so bad they know
they know it's a humanitarian crisis and
my oldest knows better than secretary of
homeland
security i just don't think they want
the optics and certainly
if it's brought up at all you know i'm
sure it's not going to be
a driving theme of a joint session
speech
they know this is where the president's
pulling
the lowest on this issue
more than any other issue out there and
so i personally don't think he's going
to spend a lot of time on it and he
should because i think it's
it is a crisis you as you noted you
formerly chaired the homeland security
committee and before becoming a member
of congress you were chief of
counterterrorism and national security
at the u.s attorney's office in west
texas
where do you hope the biden
administration focuses when it comes to
foreign policy
we've seen plans about like withdrawing
troops from afghanistan renewed talks on
um the iran deal and in every speech i
i think i've heard the president give
thus far he talks about china
and this sort of fierce competition
we're now in and have been in
how do you feel about the focus thus far
when it comes to foreign policy and
where it needs to go
well he's engaging with our allies and i
agree with that i
uh i i worry about afghanistan being
um you know look it's gone on for a long
time
uh my biggest concern is how can we
identify threats in country
and respond to those threats to the
homeland
i predict that when we withdraw
in september the taliban al qaeda are
probably going to
overrun and take over that country and
and my biggest concern is how can we you
know
respond to threats in real time you know
that could impact
uh our allies or the homeland itself
you know going back to pre-911 state i
worry about iran
too because they are getting closer to
bomb
they seem so eager to get involved in
this and back into the jcpoa
um you know just like john kerry i think
wanted just a deal not a good deal as
netanyahu would talk about um you know
right now iran's
getting very close to their 60
enrichment
within months could be at 90 percent
they have short-range missiles
and israel and the saudi peninsula are
really in the crosshairs here
they wait the congressman they are at 60
already i mean i i remember hearing
and i think it was an iranian official
saying
we're not going to be bullied if we want
to get to 60 we will but
you're saying they in that they already
have reached that point
well the itola has announced that
they're at 60
now whether that's how verifiable that
is you know there are assessments that
could be lower than that but but we do
know that they are moving
you know with a remarkable speed right
now
in their enrichment process and if they
are getting close to 60
as the ayatollah says um you're talking
about about a four-month breakout to get
to 90 percent
um and then about a year time to
develop a nuclear warhead to attach to
these short-range
missiles so if we can negotiate and look
i want the diplomats to succeed
we don't want to fail because we don't
want to go to war
one thing iran has to understand very
clearly is that the
united states of america and i think i
speak for the democrats on this one as
well
are not going to sit back lively and
allow a nuclear iran to exist
in one way or another america will
respond to that
speaking of john kerry um some are
calling for john kerry to
resign he's currently serving as a
climate envoy under the biden
administration
over leaked audio of iran's foreign
minister saying that kerry as secretary
of state
told him javad zarif that israel carried
out strikes against syrian targets
kerry's adamantly denying that this is
true but i wonder what you think of
these allegations in light of the fact
that
secretary pompeo in 2018 called kerry's
meetings
private meetings with zarif at the time
unseemly and unprecedented
and kerry himself at the time admitted
in a radio show
in 2018 that he had met with zarif uh
three or four times
well i find these allegations very
disturbing
uh we will be looking into these
allegations i think there should be an
investigation i think mr kerry needs to
come out more
strongly in his defense on this
i i think um you know i signed a
document that
requires me to when i get briefed on
classified information i certainly don't
give it to my foreign adversary
that is a huge violation of law um
if which were true should be prosecuted
but i think we need old facts you know
in front of us
i don't know if we we have all but the
one thing jessica that does bother me
to your point about what pompeo says why
is he
maintaining this relationship you know
with a former pri
you know foreign minister of iran
not exactly an ally of the united states
it's one thing like you know
great britain or france you know but to
carry on a relationship and maintain a
relationship
with the foreign minister of a major
adversary he said in his own defense
like look i shared all the information
that i got
with pompeo i shared that information um
you know that i gleaned from my
conversations with zarif with
with the state department at the time
does that absolve him of anything here
it just depends on his classified
information revealed at that time
right under the wall and he has a
federal prosecutor for many years and
i think i take that out very seriously
just to bring this back to biden's
speech tonight
the latest fox news poll found 62
percent
of people polled do not support
defunding the police but 33 percent do
and um white house spokeswoman jen saki
said tuesday that the president will
talk about police i'm just wondering
you know everybody's sort of focusing on
that 62 percent that does not support
defunding the police as being sort of a
overwhelming
amount a number of americans but still
33 percent
do support it what do you make of that
of that number
well i think it's the the whole george
floyd thing i'm glad that senator tim
scott's going to give the
the response to president biden's uh
speech and talk about you know race
relations but also talk about the
justice act
you know once again another bipartisan
opportunity
present squandered that we could we
could have passed
you know within a week or two after
georgia floyd's murder um
and that was squandered and we had a
great bipartisan opportunity and i
i you know look that was a terrible case
but
does it merit de blasio defunding the
new york police department by a
billion dollars which i've i've been
very close to them
my austin police department my city
council
defunded the austin police by 150
million dollars
for something they had nothing to do
with so i
you know i think we got to put it on
perspective as well i you know
the poi you have a hard time recruiting
people
in the police force you know that
sort of defunding and i think for the
most part people don't like this because
it makes them feel
less safe um finally um as you've
probably heard at this point
congresswoman alexandria ocasio-cortez
says she's
very happy with biden president biden
thus far um that that he has exceeded
expectations
um what do you make of
some folks in the democratic party who
maybe are to the
on the on the further left end of the
democratic party who
you know maybe were had had their
reservations or skepticisms about this
president
governing from the middle or being more
centrist being quite pleased with him
thus far
well that signals to me that um that
they are prevailing
in the policies which i find right you
know to me that's
very concerning and i you know biden
with all of his
rhetoric of unity and bipartisanship has
not really demonstrated that
and what that signals to me is that that
wing of the party is
is winning and that their policies you
know are prevailing
um and to me that's uh the wrong
direction for the country
i don't think that's where most
americans are congressman mccall thank
you so much for your time
thanks jessica i appreciate it i won't
come back back on again
this is jason chaffetz with your fox
news commentary
coming up when president biden talks to
us tonight
he might bring up covid firsts i urge
all americans don't let up now
that was yesterday when the president
announced new mask
guidelines many of us don't need to wear
them outside anymore
the odds of getting or giving the virus
to others
is very very low if you're both been
fully vaccinated
and out the open air unless you're in a
big crowd then keep the mask on
same thing if you haven't gotten a shot
yet this is another great
reason to go get vaccinated
now a message he might repeat tonight
this president has taken action on the
major
issue confronting america in his first
100 days in
juan williams is a fox political analyst
and co-host of the five on the fox news
channel
i would imagine he would go on to talk
about
economic issues and the fact that they
passed a covert relief bill that
delivered checks to 160 million people
people who had lost jobs or seen their
incomes diminished as a result of the
pandemic and people
in various states of lockdown and you
know things like restaurants clothes
help the small business owners speaking
of those small restaurants help the
small businesses
and he will make the case that he is on
his way now
and in good position politically to pass
something of an infrastructure bill that
could even do
more to get our economy going yeah this
is where we're going next there are two
big things he's going to talk about and
then they all have the american name the
american rescue plan was the one with
covert relief
the american jobs which is the
infrastructure plan and the american
families plan which i guess he's going
to speak a lot about
tonight that's also going to be on the
agenda so
the price tag on these one are around 4
trillion dollars for the two
new ones and there was also nearly 2
trillion dollars on the one that was
already passed we're talking like six
trillion dollars that's a lot of money
it is and here's the interesting part so
this discussion
in washington is very freighted and by
that i mean
you see republicans saying republican
politicians because republican voters
by and large supported the relief
packages you called it dave that gave
the stimulus checks to people that sent
out so much
help in terms of getting a lot of the
schools we open and all that
but they also like elements of what
biden is proposing in terms of
infrastructure especially if you limit
the definition to roads bridges
tunnels things like that right right
right but the definition is not limited
in the biden proposal to that no correct
you're right
it's not limited in the biden proposal
and the family's plan that you also
reference would take it even
longer along the way in terms of saying
we're looking at things like
medical help for people who have health
issues or we're looking at
child care so there's a lot going on
here but
my point to you dave is this republicans
on capitol hill
having opposed the covet relief plan
have found themselves out of step and
are now
showing some inkling of trying to say
you know what we are willing to go along
with something
in terms of infrastructure particularly
if you limit it
unlike what the biden bill is now but
limit it to specifically hard
concrete projects roads bridges tunnels
and part of that equation is also then
how you pay for it and again
republicans find themselves out of step
because they're saying
don't raise taxes on people who make
more than four hundred thousand dollars
the biden proposal and don't raise
your corporate tax rates again part of
the biden proposal
they're saying that would somehow limit
business economic growth in the country
so we're looking now at the idea that
maybe there could be some negotiations
biden says he's open to it
i want to just make one final note on
this point that
republican voters so far are
open to the idea of additional taxes
on the rich and on the corporations and
in fact in the last fox news poll
what we see is overall the american
people are very strongly in favor of
raising taxes on people making more than
the 400 000
and on corporations tomorrow marks
president biden's
100th day in office and many on the left
give him a good grade including
aoc congresswoman alexandria
ocasio-cortez
definitely exceeded expectations that
progressives had
you know i'll be fraying i think a lot
of us expected a much more conservative
administration
republicans say he's taking us down a
road towards socialism
you would be a fool to not think that
when people put out
big lies that somehow they resonate i
mean
at the moment the big one is biden wants
to take away your hamburger
i mean everybody says that's not true we
know it's not true but
it's all over the internet and facebook
and all that kind of stuff
so when you ask me about this socialism
charge
i think to myself socialism joe biden
joe biden he's been around so long we
all know him
people think of him as a political
moderate but a socialist
are you telling me that the people in
the united states
congress who are the democratic leaders
people like chuck schumer nancy pelosi
are suddenly
socialist what about joe manchin who is
a democrat from west virginia
holds such sway over the democratic vote
the ability of democrats in an evenly
divided
senate to do anything he's no socialist
now aoc some people say oh she's got to
be a socialist in your mind juan
but dave i would say to you aoc is in
new york city
she is pursuing an agenda that has
allowed her to gain reelection
and i think she gives voice to some far
left ideas
but to talk about like state ownership
of our industries to talk about the
state
dictating our paychecks i think that's
pretty strong but that's what socialism
is i don't maybe people are just talking
about something
more vague but at the moment it seems
like americans say we need government
to intervene to help us with this
pandemic to help get this economy
restarted
and to help us with the high cost of
health care
now another thing that republicans are
worried about
is what happens to the supreme court in
the first hundred days
the president has put forward a
commission to study
possibly expanding the court as an
overall reform idea
other democrats in congress have already
said we want four
more justices on the court do you think
that has
any chance of going forward here
no but again this is an idea that's been
pushed
by people who felt that they were burned
by what happened
with the current attorney general
merrick garland when he was nominated
for a supreme court seat by former
president
obama right that nomination was blocked
by republicans in the senate
and then here comes president trump and
he gets
three i repeat three nominations
successfully placed on the court
the liberals and the democrats and the
liberals all felt you know what we just
got
run over and this court is now
unbalanced
for biden's political aims he wants to
make sure that the left is heard but i
don't think
to come back to my point i don't think
you're going to see the supreme court
expanded
not in my lifetime the president made a
big deal
uh in his inauguration speech about
unity and bringing people together and
republicans and you've heard this over
and over
have said in this first hundred days
that the president really hasn't strived
for
unity he's had a couple of meetings here
and there but he's not really listening
to republican proposals
what is your reaction to that well i you
know
it's interesting i would cite a fox news
poll
the poll asked is biden doing enough to
reach out to republicans this is
specifically your point dave
and the answer came back split it was
like 45 percent said yes he is doing
enough but 42
said no he's not doing enough well
the opposite question was also asked are
republicans
doing enough to reach out to president
biden
here there was no split overwhelmingly
people said 50 plus percent republicans
aren't doing enough
to reach out and make an effort to work
with president biden
only like 30 percent said yeah
republicans are doing enough
what do you think if anything the
president will say about the border
issue because republicans have been
hammering away at this calling it a
crisis and there has been a big surge of
migrants coming here and
they've been saying that the vice
president is not doing enough and all
that so
what do you expect to hear tonight i
expect that he's going to have to
address this because that's a real
problem
and it's a real problem for him by the
way going back to the fox news poll
that's his lowest rated area in terms of
job performance overall his job
performance is like 54
positive so you know the american people
are giving him
something of a honeymoon even in these
politically polarized times
but on the issue of immigration he is
seen as failing
and people want solutions so he's going
to have to speak to this
i imagine trying to put it in terms that
are more favorable to him
he will contrast what he's doing to what
president trump did and talked about
trump separating children from their
parents at the border
harsh policies and the like and suggest
that they were out of keeping with
american values and the fact that we're
a country of immigrants so he's going to
make those points
but he's also going to have to say and
lay out
here's what i'm trying to do and ask the
american people for some time
to get that problem solved police reform
is that going to be an issue tonight as
well
i think so because again that issue is
so hot in the american mind right now in
the aftermath of the
george floyd case uh in which derek
shoving the police officer was convicted
ongoing cases now one in north carolina
and the like
i think he has great hope in senator tim
scott republican
from south carolina a black man cory
booker senator democrat from new jersey
also black
congresswoman from california karen bass
and the idea there is that if they can
get a police reform bill
written and get it passed get some
republican support sufficient
no more than 10 in the senate to get it
passed that biden will promise
in his address to the congress that he
will sign that bill
senator tim scott is going to deliver
the republican rebuttal
after the biden's speech his profile has
been raised in the last year or so
what do you think of senator scott and
do you think that maybe
he might someday run for president
i think that's in the cards uh you know
it's a very
interesting dynamic we are so
polarized at the moment and scott
because he's an african-american because
he's from the south
really has an opportunity to change
not only the republican look but the
republican
agenda to say we're interested in police
reform
but republicans trust him it could be a
bridge
that allows republicans to have some
success they were
already having some success increasing
their support among
minorities in the country so in the end
in the first hundred days has it gone
the way you expected for
president biden it's better uh i
think that we are in extremely polarized
times
before he was inaugurated we had that
january 6
riot insurrection trouble at the capitol
and all indications are most republicans
still believe that the election was
stolen it's incredible
and you know so i thought joe biden is
coming into
stormy waters and he's going to get
storm tossed
but he has stayed on his agenda
he's made it clear he's about helping
the american economy grow
he's been empathetic to americans who
have been contending with the pandemic
he's not been on twitter he's not been
given to rants and rage
and by contrast to president trump
really presents as a more you know quote
normal
unquote type of person that you can
simply trust
at the helm juan williams co-host of the
five thanks again for joining us
dave my pleasure good to be with you
new from the fox news podcasts network
my name is kennedy and welcome to
my podcast which will i humbly say
single-handedly save the world you're
welcome it's kennedy saves the world
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
it's time for your fox news commentary
jason chaffetz
what's on your mind as the 100 day mark
of the biden harris administration
approaches
the white house leadership team is
beginning to look like
obama czar's version 3.0 just as
president obama got around the messy
transparency of senate confirmation by
creating
dozens of nebulous but powerful
leadership roles
this administration is loading up with
unconfirmable
subpar appointees some with financial
ties to the industries
they regulate it's bad enough that
biden's energy secretary jennifer
granholm
has financial interest in a green energy
company
being promoted by biden harris last week
grant home did go through senate
confirmation where she committed to
resign from the board of electric
battery and vehicle maker proterra
and sell her stock she has done neither
according to reporting from the new york
post
it gets worse with more casual
appointments that receive
less scrutiny a host of questionable
candidates
have been appointed to take over
responsibilities once reserved for
cabinet secretaries
at least one of these czars is pushing
the ethical limits
by not providing financial disclosures
or signing publicly available ethics
pledges
avi garbo is essentially running the
environmental protection agency the epa
as senior counselor to the epa
administrator
senator marsha blackburn republican of
tennessee
asked to review his financial disclosure
and ethics documents
hoping to better understand any
potential conflicts
but if those documents exist the epa is
refusing to disclose them
garbo is presumably working closely with
gina mccarthy
she is the failed former administrator
of the epa under president obama
but she has returned to the biden harris
administration as the white house
climate coordinator
after her catastrophic failures
surrounding flint michigan water
and the gold king mind disaster it's
hard to imagine a scenario where she
could pass
senate confirmation even with the low
bar democrats have set
the current administration understands
this so they simply placed her
into czar status again ignoring the
united states senate
former secretary of state and u.s
senator john kerry has returned after
jetting around the world
according to npr he serves now in the
newly created position of
presidential climate envoy from this
perch he advocates for massive
reductions in energy
use from his private jet which is
estimated to emit up to 40 times more
carbon per passenger
than commercial flights again no senate
confirmation
it seems this current senate controlled
by majority leader chuck schumer
democrat of new york
and his lemming democrats have no
problem with conflicts of interest
or outright hypocrisy as long as it's on
their side
obama biden learned how to avoid the
congress
and the traditional press now the same
players are back
in different roles but more secretive
than ever
the power center of policy making right
now is not the senate confirmed
and media vetted cabinet secretaries
but the murkier senior leadership
positions
created to bypass that process
this is former congressman jason
chaffetz you can find my podcast
jason in the house at foxnewspodcast.com
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news
go to foxnews.com
from the fox news podcasts network
subscribe and listen to the trey gowdy
podcast former federal prosecutor and
four-term u.s congressman from south
carolina brings you a one-of-a-kind
podcast
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes